- You are very talented.
- Your eyes really are Hazel.
- Oh, they are.
It's so funny.
Cuz somebody asked me it was so I'm not
gonna tell that story, but I was like
I have a whole song about it, but sure.
Um yes, no, no, no they
are, but you are, you are so
talented. I love the show.
It's so good.
- Thanks
Yeah. So so good.
Meet Greg.
- Huge fan
- Oh, thank you.
- I know I was freaking out
- I'm I'm gonna be on
the couch next to him.
Oh my god
- I'm excited too like, so
wait, but you you've always
loved being on stage, right? -Yes.
From very, very young, right? -Yes.
So like what? What's
like your earliest memory
- Of that?
Oh my gosh.
Well, I danced when I
was really little, I feel
like my first play was
probably in second grade.
You know, they do those
plays elementary school.
Yeah, those like educational
plays, but this was
a Thanksgiving play.
And I think I was given the
role of Betsy and she wakes up
from a dream.
Oh no, she, she has a
nightmare and it's Thanksgiving
and all the turkeys in her
classroom chase her and are mad
that we're eating turkeys.
There was a very, it was a motivational
- Messed up message for second graders.
- Absolutely. And I
just remember being told
that I was Betsy
who was like happened to
be the lead, but I was like
I wanna be the Turkey with all my friends.
- Oh.
- And wear the paper bag and everything.
And so like my big solo was
I sang Help! by the Beatles.
- That's a rad first solo
- In like a Winnie the poo jumper.
Cause I love Winnie the
Pooh I was like, it's brown.
It's Thanksgiving.
- That's amazing.
Um did you ever perform when
you were younger like that?
- Not a lot.
I did a play.
I think I did.
Like they did some local sh
version with adults of, of
like Julius Caesar, but
they had kids in it too.
- What, what,
- and I had to, I had to walk
- for children?
- I had to walk out and
say the, you know, the ides
of March are against you
or something like that.
And I was, you know, this big
- Once again, very messed up for a
- Thank you
- These are two very, very
strange mushroom induced.
- I, I know I was like,
what were these teachers on?
They were like jokes on you, parents.
- I know.
- It's like, I love that.
I, I love that everybody
has their like stories
from childhood of like weird
things you were part of.
But anyway, but what
was the audition process
like for Emily in Paris?
Was that like nerve wracking?
- Oh my gosh.
Yeah. So I was rushing
to this audition over like a lunch break.
Cause I was doing a concert at the time
and I didn't think I was
gonna have time to go
to this audition and I really wanted to.
And so I was on the subway.
You both have ridden New
York subways, right? -Yeah
- Or are you too cool. - Yes.
- No, I've, it's not that I'm too cool.
It's when you don't
grow up in that, it's a
it's a different environment,
but yes, I've done it.
- Yes.
- So I was on a train.
That I'd never been on
before I was running late
and I like never look at my
audition sides in public.
I don't know why.
Cause it feels private.
And so, but I was cause I
was cramming these lines in.
- Yeah.
- And then I feel this tap
behind me and it's this girl
and she has all these Doc
Marten bags and she's like
I'm so sorry.
This is so random.
I just saw that it's it says
Emily in Paris and Mindy
I'm actually going to a fitting
with Lily Collins right now.
And I just so it's so random.
- Random
- We haven't cast this part yet.
And so it gets better.
And I was like, oh my gosh, the universe
I don't have to look at these lines.
I'm gonna talk to this girl and be like
what an angel meant to be?
And so it was one
of those New York moments
that went by so fast.
And so I went to the audition
and fast forward, I ended
up getting it and I was in
Paris and I told Lily this story
she's like one of my best friends.
And I was like, Lily, this is so crazy.
Like it was meant to be
I met this girl and she
was, had the Doc Martens.
And then apparently
Lily told Patricia Field
our Costume designer and her team.
And one of the associates
named Erica was like
that was me on the train.
I, I assumed it was just like an intern.
It had been months before or something.
- Yeah.
- So she came up to me
during my camera test
and was like, Ashley, I
need to tell you something.
The reason that I was even looking
over your shoulder and saw the sides was
because I had just taken
a photo of you to send
to Patricia as inspiration for
Mindy's fashion in the show.
- Oh
- Wow
- So this is
- Wow that's a picture
- which by the way,
that's its own compliment.
And like no one takes photos like
this is inspiration for a fashionable look
- Look, if you really look,
look how stressed out I am.
I'm hunched over like this.
Like
- No you look rad you look rock and roll.
Like you're in a band.
- What happened to those shoes?
- I don't know.
- I lost them
- Oh, I dunno.
I think that you're able
to buy more now -Anyways
- you're fine now.
- Yeah, but it was one
of those like New York
Isn't that crazy?
- by the way, it looks like the guy
over your, put it back up for a second.
It looks like the guy
over your left shoulder is kind of,
- he's reading too.
- Yeah there's some guy
- He's trying to get an audition as well.
Clearly.
- He wants Mindy as well.
Yeah. Everybody can feel the
nervous energy, but yeah.
I ended up wearing that hat in one
of the episodes just as
like an homage to it.
But
- that's so cool.
- I just love that.
It's like such a New York kind
of story and felt like
it was meant to be so
- It that is very, yeah.
Um oh my God.
Well, thank you so much.
I love your show.
I think you're even more adorable.
You're so talented.
No, no joke.
You're so good.
- Coming from
I'm literally like sinking
into your eyes right
now. No
- No, no joke.
You're so talented.
I was like, oh damn.
I was like, she really sing.
I was watching it.
I was so into it.
It's just such a great cast.
It's a different kind of show.
It's fresh.
I love it.
- Everyone's the best on it so love it.
Yeah.
- Thank you guys so much.